[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Ryan Shapiro
is a PhD candidate
at MIT, a former researcher
affiliate at Berkman Klein
Center for Internet and
Society at Harvard, now
the co-founder and director
of the nonprofit transparency
organization, Property
of the People.
"Political" has called Ryan
a "Freedom of Information Act
guru."
The "Nation" has
described Ryan's work
as "a ray of hope in these
dark political times."
Michigan University Professor
of Journalism and TED Senior
Fellow, Will Potter, has
called Ryan "the FBI's worst
nightmare."
Without any further ado,
I'd like to introduce Ryan.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN SHAPIRO: All
right, it's green.
Thank you so much for having me.
Is this-- is this good?
This volume?
Hooray.
All right, thank you
so much for having me.
It's a real genuine honor for
me to be here speaking with you.
So yeah, some things about me.
I'm a long time animal rights
and social justice activist,
a transparency activist,
a PhD candidate at MIT
where I am an historian of
the political functioning
of national security and
the policing of dissent.
And I'm also the
co-founder and director
of the nonprofit transparency
organization, Property
of the People.
So I'm at Google,
so I'm going to give
a talk about search protocols.
This is a talk about the FBI,
record systems, and democracy,
but first, we're going to take
just a little trip down memory
lane.
So I've always liked animals.
Here is me as a little
kid with a goat.
And I got into radical
politics and punk rock
at a very early age.
Here is me in eighth grade.
And around the same
time, influenced
by punk rock and radical
politics, I became vegetarian,
and then a few years
later, I became vegan.
Learning about how
animals are treated
on factory farms, confined
in spaces so small
they can't stand, turn
around, or spread their limbs.
And this had a big impact on me.
And so I grew up in DC
and then I went to college
at NYU for undergrad.
And while in New York, I started
coordinating above ground
direct action campaigns-- civil
disobedience style campaigns.
This is my first arrest.
I'm not the first guy
but the second guy.
We're locked in
these metal pipes.
This is the ramp to
Ringling Brothers' circus.
We are preventing the elephants
from getting into the circus,
shutting down the circus.
They weren't able
to get in but they
were able to stand above us and
the ring folks kept them there
until they urinated on us and we
marinated for hours in elephant
urine, and then we were brought
into jail in southeast DC.
Stinking of elephant
urine is quite something.
At NYU, I coordinated a takeover
of the president's office
to shut down a laboratory where
they were forcing chimpanzees
to smoke crack.
Here I am locked inside
a concrete barrel
to protest the sale of fur.
Here is another shot of that.
This is what it looks
like getting it out.
They have to use
jackhammers and--
and you know, when I left
New York, I moved to Hawaii
and co-coordinated a campaign
to shut down a captive dolphin
facility in a shopping mall.
We were making
surfboard protests.
Here, I sabotaged whale
hunts riding jet skis,
in between the gunboats
and the whales.
And so this is all in the mid
'90s, late '90s, early 2000s.
And then, around 2002, along
with some other activists
who I'd worked
with for some time,
I co-coordinated a year-long
undercover investigation
of foie gras-producing
factory farms in New York
and in California and we openly
rescued a number of animals
from those farms.
Here's me rescuing
one of the ducks
from a foie gras factory
farm in New York.
We made a documentary about it.
I did go to NYU
undergrad for film.
And we got prosecuted for
doing this in 2003 and 2004.
We were facing felony
burglary charges.
This is Sarahjane Blum.
She and I were facing felony
burglary charges in New York.
I was getting a
master's degree in DC
at the time in modern
American history.
And to my surprise, we ended
up beating the charges.
And so this brings us up to 2004
and I had a bit of a dilemma,
because in 2004, there was
this massive legislative
and legal and
prosecutorial shift.
In 2004, the FBI designated
the animal rights
and environmental movements to
the number one domestic terror
threats in the United
States, despite the fact
that neither of
these movements has
ever physically injured a single
person once in this country.
And yet, number one
domestic terror threat.
Not militia movements,
white power movements,
anti-abortion folks--
people who kill people,
people who try to kill people--
but puppy huggers
and tree huggers.
And there was also, shortly
after that, the passage
of the Animal Enterprise
Terrorism Act,
or AETA, which is a piece of
pernicious post-911 legislation
that's essentially a Patriot
Act explicitly targeting
animal rights and
environmental protesters.
And there was also
the prosecution
of some of my closest
friends and colleagues
under federal felony terrorism
charges for running an animal
rights website.
They are known as the SHAC 7.
I kid you not.
And all of this was part of
what journalist Will Potter has
termed "the green scare"--
the disproportionate use
of the rhetoric and apparatus
of national security
to marginalize animal
rights activists
and environmental activists
as threats to the state.
Will's excellent book,
"Green is the New Red,"
talks about this if you're
interested in learning more.
So, as I said, I had
something of a dilemma.
I didn't know what to do next
because the model of activism
that I'd pursued, along
with many other folks,
for the previous
decade with impunity
was overnight terrorism.
And so, like lots of folks who
don't know what to do next,
I stayed in grad school
and I started work on a PhD
at the University of California
Santa Barbara, program
in the history of
science, trying
to figure out how we got
to this state of affairs.
And then I went over
to MIT, where I am now,
finishing up my PhD there.
And so, you know,
my dissertation--
I'm interested in how we got
to this state of affairs.
How did the FBI come to
understand the animal rights
and environmental movements as
the number one domestic terror
threats in the country?
How did the animal rights
and environmental movements
first come to the
attention of the FBI?
What was the role of
industry in this process?
And again, number one
domestic terror threat?
So my professional
training as an historian
is primarily archival research--
at least it was at that time.
And while some portions
of my dissertation--
I'm looking at a 100-year span
of the use of the rhetoric
and apparatus to target animal
protectionists in the United
States--
some of it, I was
able to use archival--
you know, standard
historian's archival tools.
But for the more
modern stuff, so
starting with the emergence
of the modern animal rights
movement in the 1970s and
certainly with FBI involvement,
there's not really going
to be any archives that
are going to be of use here.
So I realized I would need--
I was like, I'll try to use
the Freedom of Information Act.
I didn't know anything
about FOIA at the time,
but I did know that it was
going to be the only way that I
might be able to get anything.
So, you know, not knowing
anything about FOIA,
I shot off a FOIA
request to the FBI
and I asked for records on me.
And the FBI turned
around and they
said they don't have anything.
They actually said they
can't find anything, but--
no records responsive to your
FOIA request were located.
I'll be honest, I
was a little hurt.
You know, I thought I was
more important than that,
but that's all right, you know?
I could take it.
It's fine.
It's all right.
But I really wanted records
and I was looking for a way
in and so Sarahjane Blum, the
activist who I pointed out
earlier, when we were arrested
for the foie gras undercover
investigation and open
rescue back in '03--
we were arrested
for the same thing
but we were arrested separately.
I was arrested just by
New York State Police,
but when Sarah
Jane was arrested,
she was arrested by New York
State Police and an FBI agent.
So I was like, OK, well
I'm not important enough.
I wasn't important enough
to warrant an FBI file,
but Sarah Jane obviously was.
I mean, there was
an FBI agent there.
So she kindly gave me
her written permission--
her consent--
to submit a request about her.
That doesn't mean the FBI
has to give me her files,
it just means they can't use her
personal privacy as an excuse
to withhold them from me.
And so I submitted
the request on her.
And again, the
results came back.
Same thing.
Hey, look, we couldn't
find anything.
I was like, well, that's
weird but all right.
I was like, OK, I know what.
I have this other
friend of mine.
The FBI has chased
her around the country
with a warrant for her DNA.
They've raided her storage
unit on multiple occasions.
They've arrested her
on multiple occasions.
She's done time for
grand jury resistance.
The FBI is obsessed
with this woman--
with this wonderful
person and activist.
The FBI is obsessed with her.
She definitely has a file
and, like, a giant file.
So she kindly gave me
her written consent
to submit a request on her.
So I was like, all right, now
we're going to get somewhere.
Eh, the same thing happens.
They turn around and was like,
no, I don't have anything.
I was like, oh, I get it.
I'm sorry.
This is my fault.
This is my bad.
I'm being lied to and I was
naive and didn't get it.
I mean, the thing is, I hated
the FBI basically forever.
I grew up as a punk rock kid
listening to the Dead Kennedys.
My first research paper ever
was in eighth grade about Sacco
and Vanzetti, two
Italian anarchists
who were ultimately murdered
by what would become the FBI--
or, well, they were executed
by the state and the FBI was--
or the Bureau of
Investigation at the time--
was heavily involved.
I read Brian Glick's
"War at Home"
about the FBI's COINTELPRO or
counterintelligence programs
where the FBI targeted
the civil rights
movements, the black
power movement,
the anti-war movement.
I read that when it came out
when I was in eighth grade.
So I hated the FBI forever,
but for some reason,
I had naively believed
that the FBI RIDS,
the Records/Information
Dissemination Section--
that's their FOIA
division at the FBI--
I naively believed that FBI
RIDS, their FOIA division,
would be not mission-driven
like the rest of the FBI
but just sort of a
bureaucratic outpost.
I was like, you know, when
I got back the third denial
letter, my friend who I know
she's got a massive file,
it's like, OK, I get it.
This is my fault.
I'm being lied to.
This is my bad.
And no one likes being lied
to, but I get real twitchy
about it.
And you know, we
all have qualities
that at some times
in our lives prove
more adaptive or maladaptive,
depending on the circumstances,
and my OCD need for
conflict and contempt
for federal
intelligence agencies,
it's not always been the most
conducive to positive outcomes.
But in this case, it
worked out very well.
And I started to become
obsessed not only
with trying to get records
about FBI campaigns
against the animal rights
and environmental movements
but trying to map out the
nature of FBI noncompliance
with the Freedom
of Information Act
because you know, the Freedom of
Information Act is federal law
and the FBI is the leading
federal law enforcement
agency in the country
and this means
we have the outrageous
state of affairs
in which the leading
federal law enforcement
agency in the country is
in routine in flagrant
violation of federal law.
And the question is, how?
How is the FBI systematically
avoiding compliance
with the Freedom
of Information Act?
And so that question
increasingly
became as and then
more important to me
than the original questions I
was asking about FBI campaigns
against animal rights and
environmental movements.
And so I started submitting
hundreds and hundreds
of experimental requests.
I got signed privacy waivers
from 250 leading animal rights
activists from the
1970s to the present,
submitting hundreds of
requests trying to get records
in different ways.
Started submitted FOIA requests
about my FOIA requests,
which we'll come back to later.
I scoured-- you know, I
was scouring FOIA case law
to try and find anything that
I could that would be helpful.
Here's my dog and
best friend, Ihi,
helping out with the
secondary literature review.
Here he is again
because he's the best.
And so, you know,
in the process,
two things became
apparent to me.
The FBI does nearly
everything in its power
to avoid compliance with the
Freedom of Information Act.
Indeed, if FOIA work
with some agencies is
akin to trying to get customer
service over a holiday weekend
from a giant telecom,
FOIA with the FBI
is akin to a street fight.
And number two, essential to
making FOIA work with the FBI,
it was developing an
intimate familiarity
with the Bureau's
FOIA-specific information
storage and retrieval systems.
And using the techniques
that I mentioned--
the experimental
techniques that I mentioned
and a bunch of others,
I did just that.
And this really
started to pay off.
If the FBI has x amount of
first-round dirty tricks
that they use to
avoid compliance
with Freedom of
Information Act requests,
you know, I mapped out
a good number of them.
And I started getting a
lot of documents-- in fact,
thousands and
thousands of pages--
about FBI campaigns against the
animal rights and environmental
movements, including--
oh, that's not where I
thought that would be.
Well, either way, so here I am.
So we'll say hi to Ihi again.
Yeah.
And the FBI said,
oh, that's real cute.
You're very clever.
Look at you.
You've got all these documents.
You should be very
proud of yourself.
Watch what we can do.
And then they sat on their
hands because the Freedom
of Information Act is one of the
most under-appreciated elements
of the entire
American experiment.
The notion that the
records of government
are the property of
the people and all
we need to do to get them is
to ask for them is radically
democratic but FOIA is broken.
And one of the main
reasons FOIA is broken
is that there are no
penalties for noncompliance.
So an agency that
doesn't want to comply,
or in the case of
the FBI, an agency
that is overtly hostile to the
Freedom of Information Act,
has no incentive to comply.
And so they just
sat on their hands.
And an agency only
has 20 working days
to comply with a request--
not to give me the records
but to process the request--
and they sat on these
requests for years.
So I sued.
I mean, FOIA's toothless
but it has this baby tooth.
There's no penalties
for noncompliance
but you can sue an agency
for failure to comply.
So I teamed up with Jeffrey
Light, who is a brilliant FOIA
specialist attorney with
politics similar to my own,
and we sued the FBI for
failure to comply with FOIA
because they took
way, way, way too long
to comply with my request--
or my requests.
And sorry, here.
That's a little awkward.
Yeah.
And so what's supposed to
happen in a circumstance
like this is you go in and
the judge is like, OK, FBI,
you're obviously in
violation of the law.
When are you going to comply?
Not when are you going
to give the documents
but when are you going to figure
out what you're going to do?
And instead of negotiating
with me via my counsel--
you know, they want to do
it in a year and a half.
I want it yesterday.
Maybe we'll agree on a
calendar of nine months.
The FBI comes in and invokes the
nuclear option of a FOIA case
called an open America state.
They say they want seven years--
actually unprecedented--
to just think
about how to respond
to my FOIA requests.
Doing so, they are relying on--
they revived a Cold
War-era FOIA secrecy
doctrine known as the
Mosaic Theory of Information
in order to argue that my MIT
dissertation FOIA research
methodologies are themselves
a threat to national security,
which is the nicest thing that
anyone's ever said about me
and will look great on the cover
of the book, but keep in mind,
the FBI is not arguing that
the release of the documents
that I've requested would
threaten national security
but rather that
deciding whether or not
to release the
documents to me would
threaten national security.
And further, the purported
risk to national security
posed by my
dissertation research
is ostensibly so grave that the
FBI can't even talk about it.
Indeed, the FBI's primary
support for its argument
came in the form of an ex
parte in camera declaration
to a secret letter from the
counter-terrorism division
of the FBI to the judge
about why they can't tell us
why my FOIA dissertation
research methodology is
a threat to national security.
And this is an especially
circular and Kafkaesque line
of argument.
The FBI considers it a
national security threat
to make public its
reasoning for considering
it a national security threat
to use federal law to request
information about
the FBI's deeply
problematic understanding of
national security threats.
And it's important to remember
that though the FBI doesn't
want damning records about
it coming out whether they
be about campaigns against
the animal rights movement,
the environmental
movement, or whatever,
that's not what this
is really about.
Rather, the FBI's
core motivation
here is maintaining
its functional immunity
from the Freedom
of Information Act.
And this brings us to
FBI record systems.
So one of the core ways that
the FBI maintains its immunity
from FOIA is through its
failure-by-design FOIA search
protocols.
Since its earliest days, the
FBI has used political dissent
as a threat, and since the
Freedom of Information Act
was first amended in
1974 to apply to the FBI
and other intelligence
agencies, the FBI
has understood FOIA
in the same light--
as a threat-- and has done
functionally everything
within their power
to avoid compliance.
Indeed, in 2009, the
National Security Archive--
a great transparency
organization based out
of George Washington
University--
gave the FBI its hoax
Rosemary Award for "worst
Freedom of Information
Act performance
by a federal agency"
for "outstandingly bad
responsiveness to
the public that
flaunts the letter and spirit
of the Freedom of Information
Act."
In like spirit, a related 2009
"Associated Press" article
decried FBI abuses
of FOIA and it
opened by asserting, "if
information were a river,
the FBI would be a dam."
So, over the years, the FBI
has established countless means
by which to avoid
compliance with FOIA.
One of the chief means by
which the FBI accomplishes
this is to search for
records in such a way
that the search routinely
fails by design.
The National Security
Archives 2009 study
found that on
average, the FBI fails
to locate any records at all
for every two out of three FOIA
requests.
That's a failure rate
five times higher
than other agencies on average.
And you could say,
well maybe the FBI just
gets a lot of crappy requests.
That's not-- that
would be wrong.
I mean, I'm sure they get
a lot of crappy requests,
but that is not what
is happening here.
So, the Freedom of
Information Act, the statute,
it doesn't require an
agency to locate records.
It requires an agency to conduct
a search reasonably calculated
to locate responsive records.
And by utilizing a deliberately
deficient FOIA search
methodology, the
FBI superficially
appears to be in
compliance with FOIA
without having to actually
locate and therefore
potentially release
many records.
So how exactly does this work?
Today we're going to take
a look at a key part of it.
So FBI RIDS-- the
FOIA division at FBI--
asserts that nearly all records
responsive to nearly all FOIA
requests will be maintained
within the FBI's Central
Records System, or CRS.
And this is problematic
on a number of levels.
There are many FBI records that
are not contained in the CRS,
including the ELSUR indices--
the electronic surveillance
records.
The FBI's indices for searching
for electronic surveillance
records are separate from the
CRS and cannot be searched
using a CRS search.
But either way, we're
not really going
to deal with ELSUR
records right now
and we're really just going
to be looking at the CRS.
So the CRS does
have a huge amount
of records in it-- about 115
million records-- not pages,
but records.
It's the FBI's main
investigative database.
And in fact, it's
basically the same CRS
that J. Edgar Hoover
helped design in 1921.
So the FBI got--
its inception was in 1908 when
the attorney general appointed
some special agents in 1909.
It took the name Bureau
of Investigation.
And between 1909 and 1921,
the Bureau of Investigation
experimented with a whole number
of records management systems
and they were all
totally failures.
In fact, it was so bad that
in 1920, the FBI gave--
or the Bureau of Investigation--
gave up entirely and just gave
all of its records to the DOJ.
In 1921, the DOJ said, no, thank
you, and gave the records back
to the Bureau of
Investigation, at which point
J. Edgar Hoover helped
design what ultimately became
the Central Records System.
Notably, Hoover's first job
was an entry-level position
at the Library of Congress,
and so he cared deeply
about records management
and brought that knowledge
to bear in designing the
CRS and it's the same CRS
that we deal with today.
But those FOIA
requests [INAUDIBLE]
that is the FBI's main
investigative database.
So, according to the FBI, the
CRS itself cannot actually be
searched.
It's a little
unclear why this is.
It's probably because the CRS
is in fact a paper database
of 115 million records.
And so, to search
the CRS, the FBI
created something
called the ACS in 1995,
which more or less mirrors
the CRS and is searchable.
Between 1921 and 1995,
there's essentially-- well,
between 1921 and
the early 1970s,
there was no automated
search capacity.
Between 1970 and '79,
there was a teeny bit.
But through '95, there was
extremely little functional
search capacity of
an automated fashion.
In '95, the ACS comes in-- the
Automated Case Support system.
And while the ACS is
definitely better than nothing,
it is still garbage.
It is a garbage search platform.
Indeed, the inherent
deficiencies of the ACS
are so severe that they extend
well beyond the world of FOIA.
In 2005, the Department
of Justice's Office
of the Inspector General
itself concluded that there
were national security--
this was the document
I wanted before.
I apologize for that.
So here we go.
What we have here--
one of the documents that I
got about animal rights stuff
showed that the FBI considered
pursuing federal terrorism
charges against people who take
pictures of animals trapped
in cages so small they
can't stand up, turn
around, or spread their limbs.
And the "LA Times"
wrote about it
and I was certainly
distressed to see my own name
under the people that
they were considering
pursuing federal terrorism
charges for taking pictures
of animals trapped in cages.
But back to the DOJ
OIG's 2005 report,
which said that there are
national security implications
because the FBI is continuing
to rely on the ACS,
which hampers FBI
agents and analysts
from adequately searching
and sharing information
from their investigative files.
The 2005 DOJ OIG
report further found
that the need for a new
automated investigative case
management system to replace the
existing obsolete and limited
ACS system is vital
to the FBI's ability
to perform its
mission effectively.
And the 2005 DOJ OIG report also
further found the critical need
to replace the ACS, the FBI's
obsolete case management
system, remains.
And starkly, the very
first recommendation
and the conclusion of this
2005 DOJ OIG report was,
"replace the obsolete
ACS system as quickly
and cost effectively
as feasible."
Yet, the FBI
continues to rely upon
this antiquated, obsolete, and
limited ACS system for FOIA
search purposes, even while
the FBI has increasingly
relied upon more modern
non-ACS search platforms
for its non-FOIA operations.
Indeed, even the FBI's own
2004 Report to the National
Commission on Terrorist
Attacks upon the United States,
the FBI'S counter-terrorism
program since September 2001,
found that the FBI's grievous
failure to identify or prevent
the terrorist attacks
of the September 11,
2001 was in part due to the
woefully deficient nature
of the ACS.
Found the FBI's 2004 Report,
on September 11, 2001,
the Bureau of
Information technology
was inadequate to support its
counter-terrorism mission.
A core element to
this deficiency
was that the FBI had a deficient
information management system.
The FBI's legacy investigative
information system,
the Automated Case
Support, or ACS,
was not very effective in
identifying information
or supporting investigations.
So the ACS is so bad
it's partially to blame,
according to the FBI,
for 9/11, and yet, this
is still what the FBI is using
for FOIA search purposes.
Additionally, the FBI's
own actions further
demonstrate that
the Bureau itself
believes reliance
on ACS searches
is woefully insufficient.
The FBI has lobbied
for and received
hundreds of millions
of dollars to develop
next-generation records
search capabilities,
in no small part
because of the FBI
and DOJ's own
assertions pertaining
to the dangerous poverty of
reliance upon ACS searches.
For example, the FBI's sentinel
database and Investigative Data
Warehouse, or IDW, which
has been referred to as a,
quote, "Uber Google."
are examples of some of these at
times wildly expensive, quote,
"next-generation FBI
search platforms"
that offer modern full-text
search capabilities.
Yet, the Bureau
nearly always refuses
to utilize these capabilities
for FOIA purposes.
Instead, for FOIA searches, the
FBI insists upon using the ACS.
So let's talk about the ACS.
The ACS is comprised of three
primary search applications
that the FBI can use
to perform to what
amounts to searches of the CRS.
One of these is the
Universal Index or UNI.
Then, there is the ICM, or
Investigative Case Management,
search application.
And then there is the ECF,
or Electronic Case File.
Now the FBI's default
FOIA search protocols
involved utilization
of the UNI to search
an arbitrarily-produced index,
or indices, of FBI CRS records
mirrored within the ACS.
The FBI has long
publicly insisted
that a UNI index search alone
is adequate for FOIA purposes,
and therefore, the
FBI nearly always
refuses to utilize either
of ACS's other two search
applications, the
ICM or the ECF.
Internally, however--
well, you know,
here is a training slide for
when to do an ECF search.
Basically, in very rare cases or
if it's a high-visibility case
so people might
notice that the FBI is
conducting a deficient search.
So yeah, we should
talk about the ECF.
So the ACS's ECF application
conducts full-text searches
of the CRS.
It's not a great
full-text search.
It's a 1995 full-text search.
But it's a full-text search.
And as opposed to the
UNI, which only searches
several limited lists of
arbitrarily-indexed subjects
of the CRS.
The ECF performs a relatively
modern full-text search
of the CRS.
So on the one hand, the UNI,
it's just a list of indexes.
It's just indices.
The ECF, it conducts
a full-text search
of everything in
the ACS, which is
most of the things that
are in the CRS, which
is what we want to do.
We really want more
than the CRS but we
don't get to deal with that.
Right now, we're just
trying to do the CRS.
We're trying to search the CRS.
So, again, the ECF
full-text searches,
it's not a modern
sentinel or IDW--
Uber Google-- full-text
search but it's
still a full-text search.
However, declares the FBI's
FOIA chief, David Hardy,
"only under extraordinary
circumstance--" oh, sorry.
Here's a screen capture
of an ECF search.
So this is what we
want them to do, right?
Like, that's sort of how
low the bar is here, right?
This is like, oh,
please, do this.
But yeah, so David Harty,
the head of the FBI'S FOIA
division, says
that, quote, "only
under extraordinary
circumstances
would the FBI conduct ECF
full-text searches of the CRS
in response to a FOIA request."
Somewhat amazingly,
the FBI insists
that ECF full-text
searches are not
more likely to locate responsive
records than UNI index
searches.
Further, the FBI argues
that ECF full-text searches
for FOIA requests
are unduly burdensome
and would be wasteful
of FBI resources.
Declared FBI FOIA chief,
David Harty, in 2014,
"full-text searches such as ECF
are considered an extraordinary
measure that is unduly
burdensome and not reasonably
likely to locate
responsive records."
And "The net result
of a full-text search
is typically a significant
use of time and resources
that yield no additional
responsive information.
As such, the ACS index
search of the CRS
is the key to
locating information
responsive to FOIA requests."
So again, searching this
arbitrarily-produced index
rather than a full-text
search is the key.
And these are submitted
under penalty of perjury.
The FBI's position here is akin
to suggesting that a search
of a limited and
arbitrarily-produced card
catalog at a vast library--
150 million volume library--
is as likely to locate book
pages containing a specified
search term as a full-text
search of a database containing
digitized versions of
most books in the library.
I mean, simply,
the FBI's assertion
is absurd on its face.
Notably, and as one can
see, in this document--
and I'll show you in a moment--
this document from 2007, for
its own investigative non-FOIA
purposes, the FBI routinely
uses the ECF application
to conduct full-text
searches of the CRS
and they don't think it's
that much of a burden.
So, here, the FBI is--
you know,
counter-terrorism division,
they're very stressed that
animal rights activists are
having their annual conference
at a convention center
hotel in DC.
I was there.
It was all right.
And, you know, the FBI notes,
again in this counter-terrorism
document and note
the date on it--
not that long before
2000 and the FBI
is spending its time looking
at puppy huggers meeting
at a conference in DC.
At this time, there is
no specific intelligence
to suggest that any participants
in this upcoming conference
are planning to engage
in criminal activity,
but these paid lobby groups
of the biomedical research
industry say that some
activists a couple of years
ago got arrested protesting
outside a McDonald's when
they had a conference
there over the summer.
And so this whole document--
this whole counter-terrorism
document-- is a big
intelligence score.
We got a list of the speakers.
Yeah, it was publicly posted.
We're trying to get people
to come to our conference.
And down here, note, a
prompt and limited checking
of initial leads
has been performed
by [INAUDIBLE] regarding
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
A review of the ACS support
utilizing free text searches
revealed the
following, which may
be of interest to recipients.
So prompt and limited review
of the ACS full-text search.
So when the FBI is asked to use
ECF full-text searches for FOIA
purposes, it is unduly
burdensome and doesn't work.
It's redundant and
unduly burdensome.
But when they need to do
it for their own purposes
because they want
to see literally
who the listed speakers coming
to town are, it's prompt,
it's limited, it's
easy, and they do it.
That's what they do.
Because it's the only
thing that make sense.
So, for FOIA purposes,
the FBI nearly always
refuses to use any of
the full-text searches
available to it,
whether it be the ACS's
antiquated but functional ECF
or the Bureau's modern Sentinel
and IDW platforms.
Instead, as noted, the FBI's
default FOIA search protocol
involves utilization
of the UNI to search
an index or indices
of FBI CRS records
mirrored within the ACS.
And this is a screen capture
of a UNI, so an index search.
The one we saw before
was the good one.
This is the bad one.
Yeah.
So, right.
So the FBI relies
upon index searches--
indices-based searches-- to
conduct FOIA searches and this
is a serious problem.
First, in order for the
names or other search terms
to be entered into an index,
hey have to be indexed.
And these are not automated
indexing processes.
It's literally a case
agent or, frequently,
his or her secretary going
through with a pencil
after they've completed
creating a document
and saying this
name, this person.
You got a 20-page report
and you want to go home.
You're underlining names, you
pass it off to your secretary,
he or she wants
to go home, right?
And that's also-- so
it's very limited.
It's not like every word.
It's the teeny minority of
words that gets indexed.
It's arbitrarily produced.
Different people are
going to index differently
and it's extremely limited.
Yeah.
Notably, this UNI
search, no records
were found, as is the
case most of the time--
two out of three times.
Even David Harty, head
of FBI FOIA himself,
concedes in court declarations
that the indexing of records
by the FBI, which are
essential to FBI UNI searches,
is characterized by a largely
discretionary and even
arbitrary set of practices
not designed or suited
for the purpose of
effectively locating records
responsive to FOIA requests.
So for example, this
is an FBI record
about spying on the
anti-apartheid movement
in the United States,
believing that
the anti-apartheid
movement and Nelson Mandela
are a Kremlin-directed
plot to undermine
American national security.
And this is what
indexing looks like.
The agent, underlining the
name or a group or a phrase
or whatever, and
then the secretary,
once he or she is done entering,
manually, the selected search
terms into the index,
we'll cross it out and say,
hey, I did it.
Right?
So here's the same document
indexed by a different office.
Notably, the ANC,
Mandela's political party,
the anti-apartheid resistance
party, South Africa,
it's indexed here.
So, conceivably-- and we'll
get to why it probably
wouldn't-- but conceivably, an
index-based search would come
up with a hit here if you
were searching for records
on the ANC but not here because
indexing is not only limited
but arbitrary.
Further, in the same
document, the exact same thing
but reversed.
Now the other document has
the index item and this one
doesn't.
South African president,
de Klerk, no index.
de Klerk, index.
Again, not only is FBI indexing
a tremendously limited practice
but it is also, especially
for FOIA search purposes--
it works well for the
FBI's purpose of they
want to be able to
retrieve the information
for their
investigative purposes,
but from a FOIA
perspective, I mean,
it's, again, limited
and arbitrary.
So, because there are
these inherent problems
with FBI records
indexing procedures,
UNI searches frequently fail
to locate a large percentage
of responsive records.
Simply, the overwhelming
majority of [INAUDIBLE] search
terms just aren't indexed.
So searches of the UNI
indices for these terms
produce no responsive results.
I mean, nothing is
indexed on this page.
So if you want
something on this page,
submit a FOIA
request for it, nope.
Here you have these things.
That's all that's indexed.
But even within UNI searches,
not all UNI searches
are created equally crappy.
Some UNI searches are far
more inadequate than others.
So UNI searches can be
performed in two primary ways.
One is to perform a UNI index
search of its main file index
and the other is to conduct
a search of the UNI's
cross-reference index.
So the FBI asserts
that a main file--
something that would show up
in the main file indexed--
is a meta-entry.
A main file.
It carries the name of someone
who is the subject of a file,
right?
If the FBI is really
interested in you--
if you're being targeted by
the FBI-- if you're relevant--
you're a main file.
What's a cross-reference
according to the FBI?
Cross-reference is defined as
a mere mention of or passing
reference to the
subject of a request
and files relating to other
individuals, organization,
events, or activities.
So let's say the FBI
is investigating you.
You'd be a main file
according to this.
The person you spoke to
at the ice cream store
before you went to rob the
bank, allegedly, you know,
that person might be
a cross-reference.
Right?
That's trivial.
Insignificant.
He's just really not important.
Further, search the
FBI, our experience
has shown that even when
cross-reference records are
actually responsive
to a FOIA request,
references usually
contain information
similar to the information
already processed
in a main file.
So it's going to be redundant.
It's insignificant.
It's redundant.
You'd have gotten it anyway.
So, with this as justification,
this main file versus
cross-reference distinction,
the FBI's policy--
their FOIA policy-- is not only
to limit searches of the CRS
to the ACS's UNI application
but to limit those UNI searches
solely to the UNI
applications main file index.
there's an exception to
this policy so if you submit
a request to the FBI and they
conduct a main file only search
and you are sophisticated enough
and have the time to submit
an appeal of that request to the
Department of Justice's Office
of Information Policy
appealing the inadequate search
because the FBI only conducted
a man file request and they
should be conducting a
cross-reference request too
and you know this, then OIP--
the Department of Justice
Office of Information Policy--
maybe nine months later, there's
a good chance that they will
ultimately remand your
request back to the FBI--
maybe it took them a year or
two years to get it to you
in the first place--
the denial letter--
the main file denial letter.
You appeal.
Nine months later, OIP remands.
A year or two later,
maybe then the FBI
does a cross-reference
search for you.
But if you appeal
inadequate search
based on the lack of a
cross-reference search,
the FBI has a policy, they are
potentially open to conducting
a cross-reference search.
And also if you sue.
The FBI will
automatically conduct
a cross-reference search
because the FBI does not
want this issue to be
before a court as case law
because it's so grossly
violative of FOIA.
The Freedom of Information
Act requires an agency
to conduct searches
reasonably calculated
to locate responsive records.
This is not
reasonably calculated
to locate responsive record.
So if you sue, automatically,
the FBI wants to moot the issue
and they will do a
cross-reference search for you.
But for the vast majority
of FOIA requesters
who neither appeal nor
litigate, they just
get a no response of
records denial letter.
We searched the main files
and didn't get anything.
So the FBI tells us that
essentially everything a FOIA
requester might
reasonably want is
likely to come up under a UNI
main file search of the ACS
and that a UNI cross-reference
search would be,
again, wasteful and
redundant, which the FBI often
continues, because
they are the FBI,
therefore it constitutes a
threat to national security,
because wasting the FBI's
time, thank you, Bin Laden.
[? Right? ?]
And so let's take a closer
look at how this actually
plays out in practice.
So we've seen what
the FBI has to say.
Maybe just because
I'm cynical, let's
take a closer look about
how it operates in reality.
So again, the FBI makes clear,
at the initial administrative
stage--
so that means when you
submit a FOIA request--
it is the FBI's policy to search
for and identify only main file
records responsive
to FOIA requests.
And here, surprisingly,
that search
resulted in no
records being located.
And again-- here.
Searches are conducted
for main files.
This is a training slide.
Searches are conducted
for main files.
Searches may also look
at reference files
if you provide
information that's
almost impossible to actually
meet their standards on
or if you appeal.
Right?
And again, but
that's years later.
So let's look at some
examples of how this plays out
in real life.
I submitted a Freedom
of Information Act
request for records
on the pro fur lobby
group, the anti-animal
rights lobby group, FC USA,
or Fur Commission USA.
2011, the FBI gives
me a denial letter--
"unable to identify
main file records
responsive to the FOIA."
This is the same
language that everyone--
that most people-- get when
they submit a FOIA request
and they get a denial.
People read it to think
that the FBI's saying
they don't have anything.
What it says is we looked and
we couldn't find anything.
What it actually says is, we
looked in one database using
one search methodology for
a very limited set of file
types and oh yeah, we
didn't find anything.
And by the way,
that's the point.
But either way.
So submitted my FOIA
request for FC USA.
Unable to identify main file
records responsive to the FOIA.
Then, with a
cross-reference search,
because I do appeal
everything and I do litigate,
you know, here is a document.
And so, again, the FBI claims
that a cross-reference--
and this comes up in a
cross-reference search
of the UNI's cross-reference
indices for records on FC USA.
So again, the FBI said
that cross-references are
mere trivial passing reference.
Here, the FBI is having a
meeting with the FC USA,
introducing an intelligence
analyst at the FBI
to a representative
from the FC USA--
this fur industry lobby group--
to be a routine point of
contact with the San Diego
division of the FBI.
Here, the police are
meeting with the FC
USA, the meeting which
is hosted by FC USA
and held at this resort.
FC USA is holding
trainings for the FBI
on how to deal
with puppy huggers.
You know.
And the FBI is giving
information to FC USA.
They have a routine
back and forth.
FC USA is teaching the FBI how
to use the FC USA's database
of animal rights activists
because the FC USA isn't--
they don't have any
of the limitations
that the FBI ostensibly
has on spying
on protected first
amendment activities.
Review and discussing how law
enforcement and the FC USA
can best complement each other.
So hardly a trivial
or passing reference.
Certainly not duplicative.
No responsive records come
up under the main file
and far from trivial.
All right.
Now, next.
Submitted a FOIA request
on my dear friend,
the legendary Steve Sipman.
Steve Sipman, in 1977,
was one of two men--
the other is Kenneth
LeVasseur-- who
participated in the
first reported animal
liberation in US history.
The liberation of two dolphins
which were at a University
of Hawaii at Navy Laboratory
in downtown Honolulu.
They called themselves
the Undersea Railroad.
Submitted this request
on Steve Sipman,
unable to identify
responsive main file records.
I also submitted a
request on Kenny--
on Kenneth LeVasseur's records
because I got signatures
from both of them.
Kenny's came back.
Now, so it turns
out, for something
to come up as responsive as
a hit on the main file index,
not only does it truly
need to be a subject
but it literally needs to be
the top line of the subject.
And, just like indexing, the
top line, it's arbitrary.
It's up to the case agent.
It could be alphabetical.
It could be
perceived importance.
It could be who
has a better beard.
Right?
Like, it's totally arbitrary.
And it can change over the
course of an investigation.
They can move it around.
And literally, a request
for Sipman, no main files.
A request for LeVasseur, main
file, because he's the top.
You can see that
Sipman's indexed.
You can see the line.
But he's a cross-reference
because he's not
the top, top line.
And let's say the top line
had been Undersea Railroad.
Then neither-- which
it easily could be.
Then neither of them would
have come up as a main file.
Let's say it had been theft of
two dolphins from the Kewalo
Basin Marine Mammal
Laboratory as the top line.
Then not even Undersea
Railroad would have come up.
And not only does it
have to be in the subject
and the top line, it has to
be all that the top line is.
So this comes up as
a cross-reference
for Nelson Mandela.
So a main file search
on Nelson Mandela
would not come up with a hit
for a visit of Nelson Mandela
to the United States.
This is a cross-reference
because it's not
Nelson Mandela on
the top line, it's
visit of Nelson Mandela
to the United States.
Similarly, also, the
cross-reference release.
Visit of Nelson Mandela to
accept his freedom award
in Memphis, Tennessee.
Not a main file search.
If you submit a
request to the FBI
and they conduct only an
index-based search and only
a main file index-based search
and you asked for Nelson
Mandela, you don't get this.
You don't get it.
And the records that I got on
Mandela showed that the FBI,
in 1990, after Mandela got
out of prison after 27 years
in prison in South Africa for
his anti-apartheid activities,
the FBI was tasked with
protecting Mandela--
when he came to
the United States
to continue his
anti-apartheid efforts,
the FBI was tasked with
protecting Mandela.
And while they were
doing that, they
took the opportunity to place
a confidential informant
within Mandela's inner
circle in the United States
to pass political information
to the FBI about Mandela
and his anti-apartheid
associates activities
in the United States.
And then let's look at this one.
TSBR, the Texas Society
for Biomedical Research,
another lobby group for
the biomedical industry,
unable to identify
main file records.
OK?
What do we got?
I appealed.
Let's look at the dates.
So I submitted the request
maybe a year before that.
They come back, tell me
they don't have anything--
unable to identify main files.
Now in 2012, after
I appealed, DOJ OIP
says, all right,
all right, yeah, OK.
We'll remand it to the FBI
to look for cross-references.
OK.
Behold, they find some.
I get them a couple--
you know, I get them
in February of this year.
Six pages.
You know.
And the first of the documents.
You know, it's more than a
passing fleeting reference.
The FBI is getting an alert
from the Texas Society
for Biomedical Research.
TSBR's been monitoring
animal rights hotlines
and it's rumored that the
widely-broadcast protests that
happen every year
are going to happen.
But OK, so you know,
we didn't get that.
And then I also got this one.
I mean, the FBI attends another
workshop held by a biomedical--
by an anti-animal
rights lobby group
to talk about animal
enterprise terrorism laws.
And again, they
come up as trivial.
The fact that the FBI
is actively colluding--
getting so much of their
information about targeting
the animal rights
environment movements,
which the FBI declares the
number one domestic terror
threat in the United States--
getting this
information directly
from the corporate interests who
are opposing the animal rights
movement.
Yeah, it is anything
but trivial.
And again, literally the line
is actually the entire top line,
but because there's a little
bit after that, we don't get it.
But OK.
OK.
So I sued and got processing
notes from this FOIA request
and we're going to come
back to that in a moment.
So this is from
the second passage.
This is after the remand, right?
So I just got the documents
that is remanded in 12
and they searched again.
They did a
cross-reference search.
They located the six pages
in those two files, 2012.
OK.
Because they did a
cross-reference search.
And here is the search slip.
And these are going to
become important in a minute.
This is the search slip for
the second request when they
did a cross-reference search.
You can see, even though no
responsive records came up
when they just did a main
file search, here we go.
Cross-reference search
brings up the two things,
including the FBI going to
the meeting held by TSBR.
I also got the FOIA search
slip for the first request
and they came up with--
they found them then
but they still gave
me "no responsive main file"--
a denial letter.
So it's not just--
I mean, so they
actually conducted
a main file and a
cross-reference search here
but they simply chose
not to give them to me
because the policy
is not to give it.
It's not just that they're
not conducting them.
They're not giving them
out even if they find them.
Literally, they found them,
and in that first document,
they gave me a no responsive
main file records were found.
It's true because of how
they define main file records
but they literally
even found them
and didn't give them to me.
Right.
So there is also one
additional possibility
here as to why the FBI
didn't give me these records
and that's that
they're control files
and the FBI black-balls control
files-- control files just
mean it's sort of a meta file
and the FBI doesn't give out
those records for
no good reason.
They just say they
are black-balled.
And then Jason Leopold,
a great journalist
who I work with sometimes,
did an expose or an article
on black-balling and then
the FBI continued doing it
but just changed the
name to analyst removed.
But either way.
So let's talk about
search slips for a moment.
How much time do I have?
SPEAKER: I think
you can keep going.
There is one question
which actually
relates to search slips, so if
you want to start with that,
I can--
RYAN SHAPIRO: Cool,
yeah, because I'm
going to talk about that
now so that's perfect.
What's the question?
SPEAKER: One second.
RYAN SHAPIRO: I tend to be a
bit loquacious so I can go over.
Sorry about that.
So just to illustrate
how far the FBI will
go to conceal the deliberate
and unlawful inadequacy
of their FOIA searches--
their default FOIA
searches-- we're going to
look at an ongoing FOIA
lawsuit of mine, which is a
lawsuit for FOIA search slips.
So, some time in 2010, prior
to that-- prior to 2010,
you request a FOIA search slip,
the FBI, more often than not,
would release it to you.
Some time in late
2010, the FBI stopped.
They didn't give
any explanation.
They say, hey, no response
to main file records.
We looked and didn't
find anything.
What do you mean you looked
and didn't find anything?
You have it.
You generate it with
every FOIA request.
Nope.
I don't know what you mean.
You know?
By early 2012, the
FBI and DOJ jointly
came up with an explanation
or a justification.
I mean, the bottom
line is, the FBI just
doesn't want people seeing
how bad their searches are.
But in 2012, the FBI
and DOJ jointly come up
with a formal policy and
supposed justification for it.
And the policy they said was
the FBI is not going to give out
any search slips for
investigative records that
are less than 25
years old and it's
justified on the basis
of FOIA Exemption 7E.
FOIA has nine exemptions.
So legitimate reasons that an
agency is permitted to withhold
records.
So you see things redacted, B5.
That's exemption B5.
B5 is the "withhold it
because you want to"
exemption, as it's
commonly known.
But deliberative process.
B6 is personal privacy, so
it'll be someone's name.
There are nine FOIA
exemptions and there are
subdivisions of them--
B7 A, B7 D. But anyway, there
are nine FOIA exemptions,
with subdivisions, and the
FBI says, we're not going
to give out any search slips--
just categorically, not
going to give out search
slips because 7E.
That's notable because 7E
is the FOIA exemption that
prevents disclosure
of information that
would reveal law enforcement
techniques not generally known
to the public.
So secret law
enforcement techniques.
The FBI claims that
giving out this
would give the public
information on secret law
enforcement techniques.
How they search
for FOIA records.
So in 2012, along with
some other requesters,
I sued, challenging
this policy itself.
And then in February
of 2014, the FBI
gives its first
official explanation of,
well why is that 7E?
What are you talking about?
And how are they protecting
a secret law enforcement
technique by not giving
out FOIA search slips?
And the answer that
the FBI gave in court
has to do with FOIA exclusions.
So FOIA has nine exemptions,
which an agency, as I said,
can use to
legitimately withhold.
They can also abuse
those exemptions
but they can legitimately
withhold records
under those exemptions.
The records are
subject to FOIA, it's
just those individual
records that would violate
someone's personal privacy.
I mean, I can't
request your FBI file
even though you are
allegedly accused
of robbing this bank
because you haven't given me
your personal consent.
B6, B7 C, personal privacy.
That's reasonable.
FOIA exclusions, we can thank
the Reagan administration for.
The Reagan administration
and Attorney General Ed Meese
under Reagan, they were
real stressed back in 1974
when FOIA was amended to
apply to the FBI and other law
enforcement.
Intelligence agencies.
The military.
That this was really damaging
the national security.
And so in '86, attorney
general Ed Meese
pushed through, under the guise
of fighting the war on drugs,
all these revisions
to FOIA which
really eroded a lot of it.
And one of the
major parts of what
the '86 FOIA amendments did
was to include exclusions,
which are just, hey,
the agency doesn't
want to tell you that
these records exist
and so they're going
to lie to you about it.
They're going to say--
you know, you request
records, they find records,
and they're going
to say, because it's
such a national
security problem for us
to admit that the
records exist--
and we can't even say-- we
can neither confirm or deny.
We're just going to deny.
That's an exclusion.
The records are actually
excluded from FOIA.
They're not subject to FOIA.
And the FBI said that
they can't give out
FOIA search slips
because maybe we'll
be able to figure out that an
exclusion was used somewhere.
Keep in mind that last-- in
2016, the FBI used exclusions
93 times.
They have to report how many
exclusions they use a year.
That's out of roughly
14,000 requests
that the FBI processed.
But the FBI says
a savvy requester
might be able to figure out
if an exemption is being used.
It's unclear how because I don't
think it's going to be, like,
stamped exclusion,
so it's unclear how.
I mean, as we can see,
there's lots of reasons
that the FBI might not give out
documents even if they found
them, but either way, the FBI--
so the FBI claims that
disclosure of search slips
might help a requester deduce
the use of an exclusion
and argues that the FBI--
you know, that exclusions are
law enforcement techniques not
generally known to the public.
And so the FBI is
arguing here that it
can't release FOIA search
slips under 25 years old
because the FBI claims that
lying to FOIA requesters
is a law enforcement
technique not generally known
to the public.
And like, no, for real,
use of FOIA exclusions
as a law enforcement subterfuge.
According to the FBI, the use
of subterfuge, ruse, or a cover
is a fundamental law enforcement
tool technique or procedure
whereby an investigative
agency employs a form of cloak
to cover the true nature and
scope of investigative efforts
to detect criminal activity and
safeguard national security.
Functionally, there is
no discernible difference
between using intentional
misinformation
from an undercover agent or an
informant in the authorized use
of exclusions in response
to a FOIA request
for investigative records.
No discernible difference.
In both instances, the
subterfuge of misinformation
functions as a
protective mechanism
to protect the integrity
of sensitive FBI criminal
and national security
investigations.
So, for real, the FBI is saying
that lying to FOIA requesters
is a secret law enforcement
technique not generally known
to the public and that's why
you can't see FOIA search slips.
The judge in January
of 2016 said, no.
No, FBI.
That's not right.
Exclusions are not law
enforcement techniques.
They're law.
They're part of the statute.
They're not a law
enforcement technique,
they are literally the
law, so you can't do that.
You can't categorically
withhold FOIA search
slips on the basis of 7E.
You know, you've got to
give me the search slips.
But then the FBI turns
around and says, hey, judge,
you know what?
You know that policy you
just ruled on and said
we can't use it anymore?
Yeah, well we don't actually
have that policy anymore,
and in fact, like, we
haven't for, like, a year.
We got rid of it
like a year ago,
we just didn't bother
to tell you or anyone.
We just let everyone
fight about it for a year
and didn't bother to tell
you that we got rid of it
and we have a new policy.
And you know, because we have
a new policy which is basically
just the same policy just
tweaked a little bit,
we should get to
fight about that now.
We should get to have a whole
new round of briefing on that.
And because it's new and so we
should get to fight about that.
Basically start the trial over.
You know, because as I said,
we got rid of that policy
like a year ago, so, like, your
ruling doesn't matter, judge.
And not only that, the
FBI is like-- and yeah,
I'm totally doing
this verbatim--
also, judge, by the way,
not only should we get to,
like, fight about
our new policy now,
but we should also get to
introduce new exemptions now,
too.
I know we said 7E
before and I know
that, like, we have to
introduce all our exemptions,
like, upfront at once, otherwise
the case will literally go on
forever, and we only did 7E
but we want a whole bunch
of new ones now too.
And continued the FBI,
and I'm quoting here,
yeah, you know, I know
we were supposed to,
but like, we didn't, so we
should get to do it now.
We weren't acting in bad
faith, we just basically
didn't think we'd lose and
so we didn't bother to do it,
so now we want a do-over.
And in this do-over,
we're not only
going to rely on our new policy,
which is the same policy, just
tweaked a little, but
we're also beyond just 7E,
which we're using in the
new policy, just tweaked.
We're also going to bring in
exemptions 1, 3, 5, 6, 7A, 7C,
7D, and 7F.
This case actually
warrants its own talk.
It just goes on forever.
But the judge, while pissed at
the FBI for obvious reasons,
essentially gave the
FBI almost everything
they wanted, because
at the end of the day,
even judges who are
skeptical, end up
balking too much of the time and
the FBI turns around and says,
really, judge?
Really?
You know national security
better than the FBI?
Oh, where'd you go to
national security school?
Because we're the FBI and I know
it doesn't seem like a big deal
to you, but do you want
the next twin towers
falling on your hands?
Because that's what
it's going to be
and we're going to
make sure everyone
knows it when you
cause it to happen.
So you want to release
records on puppy huggers?
You want to release
FOIA search slips?
You think you know national
security better than the FBI?
We're going to make
sure everyone knows it
when people die on your watch.
And the judges, far
more often than is
acceptable in a democracy, they
cave and defer to the agency.
So when the FBI screams
national security,
even for FOIA search slips-- and
that's what exemptions 1 and 3
are about here--
judges cave.
And this case is ongoing
and we're still fighting it.
But again, remember, all of
this happening in this case
is occurring primarily just
so that the FBI can prevent
FOIA requesters from seeing how
deliberatively shitty FBI FOIA
searches actually are.
So, as I said, FOIA's one of the
most underappreciated elements
of the entire
American experiment.
The notion that the
records of government
are the property of
the people and all
we need to do to get them is
to ask for them is radically
democratic but FOIA is broken.
And this is just one part of
the ongoing crisis of secrecy
we now face.
A Harvard historian of
science, Peter Gallison,
has shown that the universe
of classified knowledge--
published classified
knowledge-- now
exponentially exceeds
the universe of published
unclassified knowledge.
And this disparity
grows worse by the day.
Literally, the
universe of published
unclassified knowledge
is dwarfed exponentially
by classified knowledge.
The vast majority of published
information in the world
is inaccessible without
security clearances.
And classification is just
one part of the problem.
Most of the records I'm
seeking from the FBI
here aren't classified.
The government just
won't give them up.
In fact, the FBI and DOJ invoke
classification only about 5%
of the times when it
denies FOIA requests.
95% of FOIA denials are not
pertaining to classified,
they just deny them
for whatever reasons.
7E is not classified, it's just
law enforcement techniques not
generally known to the public.
Secrecy is a cancer on
the body of democracy.
And you know,
increasingly, my focus
has been on
transparency activism,
and along with Jeffrey
Light, my amazing attorney,
we've been scaling
up our efforts.
And around the time
of the election,
we incorporated as a
nonprofit, a 501 C3
transparency organization.
We've been joined by the amazing
Sarahjane Blum, the woman who
was on the cover of the
documentary and who also,
they said, did not have an
FBI file, which she does.
And yeah, we started with
a successful crowdfunding
campaign.
We're currently in
our startup phase
and now we are
building capacity.
I'm proud to
announce that we just
hired our first employee,
our new attorney,
the brilliant Gunita Singh.
And some highlights of our
successes so far include--
oh, I meant to have that up.
All right.
Yep, Property of the People.
This is the name of
our organization,
coming from our motto,
"the record of government
are the property of the people."
Check us out on Twitter.
There's our web page.
Some of our successes include--
you know, some of these
are before we incorporated
but had still the same team.
Exposing the now
earliest-known FBI utilization
of classified
remote installation
to circumvent
encryption happened
to be against animal
rights activists
who are friends of mine, 2003.
We also exposed that
the DOJ unlawfully
failed to report details of
that to Congress, as they
are required to
do, and we've got
a new project looking into
broader issues associated
there.
We exposed that the FBI
spied on Nelson Mandela
and viewed him not only
as a communist threat
but planted a confidential
informant in his inner circle
when they were supposed
to be protecting him.
We exposed that the American
Egg Board, a USDA entity,
was unlawfully colluding
with the egg industry
to prevent Hampton
Creek, a manufacturer
of egg-less mayonnaise,
from being able to succeed
as a corporation.
The president of the
American Egg Board
was forced to resign in
disgrace as a result.
We exposed FBI policy of
warning its technical agents not
to share details of its
technical surveillance
with prosecutors and
defendants alike.
And most recently, and this is
after incorporation as Property
of the People, I mean,
now we focus a huge amount
of our resources, which are
limited, but nonetheless,
on the Trump administration.
And so, recently, we exposed--
here's a document that we got,
which shows a National Security
Council payment to Trump's
Mar a Lago luxury resort,
which is likely a violation
of the Constitution's
domestic emoluments clause--
literally a
constitutional violation.
And yeah.
So democracy cannot meaningfully
function without an informed
citizenry and such a citizenry
is impossible without broad
public access to records about
the operations of government.
This has always been the case,
and given President Trump
and his administration's
overt contempt
for transparency
in a free press,
it has never been more so.
And of course, Google
itself is in the business
of providing information to
the people to create good.
And when the majority
of published information
in the world is kept hidden
from public view, when
false news dominates and the
actual actions of government
are kept secret, this is a
problem not only for democracy
but for Google as well.
It's not surprising
those in power
wish to keep their
actions secret.
What's surprising is how
readily we tolerate it.
I'll say it again.
The records of government are
the property of the people
and it's time we reclaim them.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: When you
file a FOIA request,
there's a section
in which it asks
you something
along the lines of,
how hard do you want us to try?
I.e., how much money
are you willing
to spend on us going above
and beyond a normal lookup?
What's that actually for?
If I said I'm willing to
spend $1,000, what happens?
RYAN SHAPIRO: Sure.
That's a great question.
So they're not really asking
how hard you want them to try.
Just as the agencies,
and especially the FBI,
use deficient FOIA search
protocols as a barrier
to preventing people from
conducting successful FOIA
requests, agencies, certainly
very much including the FBI,
use FOIA fees as a
way to do the same.
So they're not actually saying
they're going to work harder.
The FBI is interested
in preventing people
from submitting
successful FOIA requests.
And so when they're saying, how
much are you willing to pay,
they're trying to figure out
if they can make you go away.
Can they make you go
away because they're
taking too long?
Can they make you go
away because they're not
locating the records?
Can they make you go away
because they're saying,
we're going to charge you
a lot of money for it.
And there's all sorts of fees
that the agencies can charge.
They can charge for a search,
review, or duplication fees.
And fees, I mean, since FOIA
was amended in '74, I mean,
there's been a lot of talk about
how agencies use fees as speed
bumps on--
I'm trying to remember
the metaphor they used.
Something like speed bumps on
the highway for information.
Either way, so
what's going on there
is the agency is trying
to scare you off.
What I would
encourage you to do--
and I don't know this
individual situation,
but FOIA requesters can
ask for a fee waiver
and they can also ask for
placement in a particular fee
category.
So if someone's a
student, someone
should request placement
in the educational--
what one should do if they're
looking for these ways to get
out of paying fees-- legitimate
ways to get out of paying
fees--
I request a waiver of fees
and I also request placement
in x, y, or z fee category.
So educational fee
category or representative
of the news media fee category.
This way, agencies-- if
you get either of those,
the agencies can't
charge search fees,
and search fees can be $45 an
hour and the agency can charge
as much--
they can say it's
going to take us
1,000 hours to search for
stuff that you're requesting.
We don't know if we're
going to find anything
but you're going to owe us
the money no matter what
and you've got to pay
half of it up front
and a search requires
this level of analyst
and so that's $45 an hour so
you owe us a whole lot of money.
Are you sure you want
to go forward with this?
And so if you can get either an
educational requester status--
fee requester--
like fee status--
or representative
of the news media,
agencies are no longer
allowed to assess search
fees or review fees
and then you're stuck only
with duplication fees.
You know, which aren't really
going to go above about like
$0.10 a page, which, while
it can still be onerous,
it's not $45 an hour unlimited
and independent of whether
or not you get records.
AUDIENCE: Cool,
thank you so much.
SPEAKER: Thank you, Ryan.
RYAN SHAPIRO: It's
an honor to be here.
I really enjoyed it.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]